So when you're considering known
ordinary or altered states,
one of the first questions is what do
they feel like what's actually going on
in those places and spaces,
and one of the challenges in coming up
with a good and consistent answer,
not just for a specific state like
meditation or a flow state or a
psychedelic state,
is how do they all,
what qualities do they all share?
Because each of those communities of
practice over central decades,
centuries and even millennia,
have accumulated their own storytelling
or content about what the state and they
access are or what they mean and where
you're supposed to go through them.
So for instance,
if you were a Buddhist meditator,
you will be instructed in all sorts of
stages and levels and progressions of
non ordinary states of consciousness
ranging from waking state all the way to
white light,
voice to Buddha consciousness,
etc.
If I am a peasant farmer in India and I
have a non ordinary state experience,
I might experience ganash right?
That the elephant god in a rice patty.
If I'm a peasant in Mexico,
I might experience the virgin of
guadalupe hidalgo,
right?
If I'm a coder in silicon valley,
I might experience the matrix and code
mode.
This is ones and zeros streaming all
night is I bang away on my keyboard and
the reality is is that underneath those
experiences are far more alike than the
wrapping paper.
The narratIve wrapping paper of what
people see based on culture accustom
biography and what we.
What we attempted to do was create a
functIonal framework that lets us talk
about these things as apples to apples
and really see the similarities and what
we realized is that because of the
neurobiology,
there are four qualities that tend to
arise pretty consistently regardless of
which door you go through to get into
these northern states and they a
selflessness,
timelessness,
effortlessness,
and richness or stir for short and
selflessness tends to happen because the
areas of our brain,
specifically the prefrontal cortex,
but including additional networks that
connect often turn off or completely
light up.
Either way,
they knock out our everyday waking sense
of self consciousness and self
awareness.
So we ended up momentarily lost our
inner voice,
lost our inner critic last,
our jimminy cricket,
and we are in a state of not thinking
about our thinking.
Timelessness happens for a similar
reason as as basically different parts
of our brain light up and turn off.
Our ability to calculate time gets
knocked out because it is a is a
comprehensive measurement.
It's not.
It doesn't just occur in one single
location in our brain.
So when we start knocking out parts of
the networks,
we lose our chronometer and all of the
neurochemistry,
right?
Focusing attention,
learning drives our attention.
We dropped out of daydreaming about the
past or the future and we get absolutely
sucked into the immediate present
moment.
So a feeling of timelessness comes with
it.
The effortlessness is just,
it's no longer about what I'm trying to
do.
It's not about exerting grit or will
power,
which has been,
you know,
a lot of people have been talking about
and writing about these days and it's
literally in the sort of almost in the
biblical sense,
sort of not my wIll,
but thy will.
I feel myself swept along.
And it can be I'm just self propelled
and it feels awesome or it's terrifying,
but I don't have a choice,
but either way it's not me plotting one
foot in front of the other to get to a
goal.
I've decided so that's the
effortlessness and then the final bit is
rich is the richness and that's arguably
the whole shooting match.
Because when I knock out my self
consciousness,
I don't have a voice inside my head,
second guessing,
filtering when I'm not in the past or
the future.
I'm just in the deep present.
When I am effortlessly being propelled.
The next thing that consistently seems
to happen is we have access to far more
information than we do in our regular
waking state and that is when we go from
conscious processinG,
which is very limited and narrow to
unconscious processing,
which is faster and vaster.
And Dr. David eagleman,
who's at stanford,
who's a friend and a colleague and a and
a board member of ours at the flow
genome project,
will constantly makes that case that
that really it's as if our conscious
mind is sort of like the headlines of
tomorrow's newspaper reporting on the
reality of today and when we get into
non ordinary states,
because of the all of the shifts and
brain function and,
and hormones and neuro electricity,
we have access to more of that
information in real time.
And,
and the results often feels
supernatural.
People in the past historically have
assigned this to the gods,
to the muses,
to fate,
to possession,
to angels.
You name it,
right?
And we've preTty much exhausted the
gamut of all the ways we could say,
this is just too much.
This is too cool,
let's do inspired.
It's too,
it's too informed to possibly be me.
So we've assigned it supernatural
origins,
but in reality we now know it might just
be super hyphen natural.
It's just us in an automated state.
It's,
it's,
it's biG data for our minds.